in the devastating aftermath of the
botched VIP pedophile investigation the
retired judge who reviewed operation
Midland came to a clear conclusion the
instruction to believe a victims account
should cease Sir Richard Enrique who
reviewed the way the Met handled the
fantasies Karl Beach's allegations also
said it's the duty of an officer to
investigate facts and the policy of
believing victims will generate
miscarriages of justice so why does new
guidance issued last month by the
College of policing say anyone who makes
abuse claims should automatically be
considered a victim with the intention
that victims are to be believed this is
a license for even more dangerous
fantasies to come forward and just think
if this is what can be done to the
reputations of some of the most powerful
people in the land god help the ordinary
man and woman in the street the college
of policing terms of reference are to
provide the skills and knowledge
necessary to prevent crime protect the
public and secure public trust their new
guidance on historical sex abuse would
do the complete reverse strong stuff I
end to agree with you about it I think
what we've seen is a failure to balance
out the presumption of innocence with
the insistence that victims must be
believed however fantastical the
allegations as we saw in the case of car
Beach car beaches allegations against
household names who were dishonored
sometimes and went to their deaths
without having had their names cleared a
completely shameful episode and Richard
Enriquez gave a statement and there was
an absolute catalogue a litany of the
failures of the Metropolitan Police that
he pointed to so let's just remind
ourselves of some of the conclusions
that Sir Richard Enriquez made in his
review into operation Midland that went
so badly wrong the review said poor
judgment and a failure to accurately
evaluate known facts led to the
investigation of prominent public
figures it claimed
a major contributing factor was the
culture that victims must be believed
and it says several failures can be
explained by a disproportionate belief
in the witness known as NICs credibility
you see in my view it completely goes
against the whole tenor of the British
justice system you're innocent till
proven guilty but the moment they
decided car-boot was a victim we had an
extraordinary press comments were very
senior police officers said his
allegations were credible and true what
right of the police officer got to say
the allegations are true that's what the
court does but it was because according
to an records report which was brilliant
nine months it took him to write it they
started from the assumption that this
man was telling the truth even though he
was alleging a former prime minister a
future Home Secretary a future head of
the Armed Forces ahead of them high five
a heavy head of mi6 and a former MP had
raped and murdered children
extraordinary just let's hear from the
Metropolitan Police and the Deputy
Police Commissioner Sir Stephen House
serious mistakes were made in operation
Midland and we have apologised for those
I apologise for them again today however
we do not agree with everything Sir
Richard wrote in his report the
allegations Nick made were grave and
warranted investigation and we believe
those involved in applying for the
search warrant acted with due diligence
and in good faith at the time
I am deeply deeply sorry for the
mistakes that were made and for the
ongoing pain that these mistakes have
caused to list the mistakes pushing it
on I mean in order for that not to
happen again should we call victims
complainants yes so why is the quality
of policing which sets the rules by
which the police operate I might add the
chairperson of the college of policing
has never been a police officer he never
worked in the police why are they
sticking with this tired because this
was about incompetent police and this
guy said the charges warranted
investigation yes they did
but they weren't investigated the names
of those guys of Leon Brittan of Harvey
Proctor of Lord Rama
hot out there and let's not forget who
put them out there it was Tom Watson who
shamefully abused parliamentary
privilege the Deputy Labour leader to
actually name a new he hasn't no he
hasn't apologized but the thing is an
apology isn't done let me just say I
also want to say as well this cause
inter to question not just the
impartiality of peace but their
intelligence seriously just an wrong
with their morality because they heard
the names have a couple of posh Tory
people and thought we loved it hey every
Leggett will have him and they didn't
bother to litigate let me just the
College of policing we've got to say
give their account of it yeah they say
following the Henriques review the
college examined the evidence on belief
which demonstrated a key reason for
victims not disposing abuse was fear
that they would not be believed we
engaged extensively across policing and
MEC amended that the National Crime
recording standard reflects a balance of
believing an allegation at the point of
recording followed by an impartial
investigation which is led by the
evidence whether that leads towards far
away from their Legation but that's not
what they've done now see the point
you're saying you're if you complain of
an historical sex abuse that you are to
be okay and I think this now leads us to
actually I think we've now got to change
the law completely I think you should
not be named in a sex case less you've
been charged exactly he was named if you
remember in it child abuse allegations
being arrested on a preposterous
allegation is one thing but having that
arrest publicized is another while I was
still in the Charing Cross police
station being questioned every relative
I have in the world was approached by a
member of the British media and that and
that's exactly what we're talking about
what I think these pulleys have done in
not investigating properly they will now
stop rape victims women women or men
rape victims coming forward they've
actually made it harder for them because
the believing thing now they have been
told that that they can't actually do
that they have to investigate we know
they're not investigating so it's going
to make it much
for women I think to come forward their
sloppiness and their and confidence so
that's kind of the point
it's we have this all-or-nothing
approach when it shouldn't be like that
there's that there's a serious
difference between saying anybody who
makes an allegation must be believed
under all circumstances and then we
pursue the react you see as if we know
for sure they're guilty and saying that
if somebody makes an allegation of
sexual misconduct then the balance of
probability shifts away from the
automatic presumption of innocence and
police have to pursue it neutrally now
let's not forget if somebody makes an
allegation that is not some throwaway
thing they are putting their point in
the gun at themselves as well as well as
the accused person because we've seen
what happened with Christine Blasi Ford
when she made the allegation against
Afghans Brett Kavanaugh her life was
torn apart in the media so people do not
do this lightly so let's not forget that
kind of Carl beech did win that please I
remember watching it on the news that
night when that policeman said we
believe that what Nick is saying is
credible and true is that you changed
the home did you change the whole
investigation it certainly certainly yet
suddenly Nick the fantasies was being
believed by the police and there hadn't
even been a trial I believe I believe
yes because Chris the Didache said she
heard exactly what you heard and thought
that can't be right she did nothing she
was assistant commissioner what's his
name and I hope can have he was in
charge at the time he's now sitting on a
big fat pension and and in the Lord and
no one's asking about that it wasn't an
error by that police constable peace
officer in that press conference it was
agreed beforehand they would say it was
credible and true devastating Harvey
Proctor I interviewed him it was so
emotional to interview him because he
said 20 police officers came to his home
he said I'm very worried about it's
leaking it won't leak in the press he
turned on sky the next morning he was
leading them leading the news
absolutely anonymity and recharge and
and he might go beyond just sex crime
yes let's hear what Harvey Proctor had
to say he said this on sky last week ok
the premier police authority in the
country
believe that I was a serial child
murderer that has been a heavy burden to
bear as I think is well-known as a
result of what happened in operation
Midland I lost my job my home and my
repute I am not the same man as I was in
March 2015
I doubt I ever will be
Harvey Proctor being very dignified
after his ordeal do you think Andrew
that if we did extend anonymity to the
those accused of rape it would do
something to address the situation we
have now which is the conviction rate
for rape is so low that some people are
saying the crime has essentially been
decriminalized yeah and of course the
argument about naming a suspect early on
is that if there are other victims
they'll come forward because they've
been named in the press of an intellect
yeah but I just think now the damage
that has been done not just to these
people's reputation but young men who
have been named in a number of rape
cases where it's unraveled if you're 22
and you're named in a rape case and it's
helped truth and you know the way the
police officer would just support the
way he apologized no they may have
apologized but these there's still no
acknowledgement of what they've done to
people's lives of the damage they've the
worst police investigation is account
you you introduced Tom Watson into this
so I ought to just say what he said
which is I have always said that it
wasn't my place to judge whether sexual
abuse allegations were true or false
that was to the police the police asked
me to encourage the hundreds of people
that came to me with stories of child
abuse to report their stories to the
police that is what I did so that was
what Tom Watson as the statement is
giving us